this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by ritual
and keeps more on that later let's get
into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryansickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
the honeydewpodcast.com is the website
for the show
make sure you are subscribed to the
youtube channel don't just watch hit
that subscribe button
and uh look if you're in for more you
need to have your due
we got the patreon community growing and
growing it's the stories
i'm the the [ __ ] we have coming out you
guys i
i can't even get over it it's been a lot
of fun uh
sign up if you can do it it's five bucks
a month if you sign up for a year or
more
you save on over a month of free
episodes all right um
i record here at the santa monica music
center so if you need musical
instruments or lessons for your kids
santa monica music center is the spot
they offer online classes
if you go to santa monicamusic.com and
use the code honeydew they'll waive the
registration fee and give you one free
lesson when you sign up for a package
that's it all right now if you're new to
the show welcome
uh what we do over here we highlight the
low lights i always say these are the
stories
behind the storytellers and it is a
pleasure to have this storyteller return
especially this week via buffalo y'all
sitting across from me
just potter everybody what's up what's
up go bills baby welcome back congrats
oh yeah
congrats you look good yeah smash the
tables i've seen people throwing babies
through tables
yeah that's a new thing that's a new one
people are like oh welcome to the world
listen i'll say this i'm not in favor
obviously of throwing a baby through a
table but if i only have two choices
between a [ __ ] uh gender reveal party
or throwing a baby through a table i'm
gonna say you gotta throw your baby
through a table it only hurts the baby
it doesn't mean a forest fire
yet thankfully but they do do the i
think they're adorable frankly
they're just like rest them on it
welcome to bill's mafia
and they lower them on to the table
that's so cute people get really up in
arms there's a polarized
fan base about the tables you realize
yeah
some people are like that's a terrible
thing
these idiots out there who [ __ ] let
them break their [ __ ] legs you know
what i mean
i'm for all of it the running of the
urinals at preakness used to be one of
my favorites watching those guys go
across
i mean we [ __ ] like that go ahead a
bill's tail have you been to a bill's
ticket
so i wanted to tell you first of all
promote everything quickly oh
yes i mean not thankfully but
unfortunately not much to promote uh we
i do have the josh potter show that
comes out on youtube every tuesday
on uh the ymh youtube channel also
i'm going to be at the west palm beach
improv on march 21st
that is my only date on the books for
2021 so
hopefully people come out to that but
that's it as far as plugs oh twitch.tv
josh underscore potter you can see me
stream on there
uh while i lose my mind every day in
this quarantine
you can watch me ramble to space while
they place fake sports
um very good very good i yes i have
actually i
years ago when when the colts had left
baltimore we didn't really have we
didn't not really we didn't
have a team um and i just didn't want to
go steelers and redskins because they
were right there at first i liked the
seahawks back when dave craig and steve
largent would light it up i love those
colors
i had that old do you remember the metal
trash can back in the day that was like
the wrap of the team
yes yeah yeah yeah one of those i had a
seahawks and i had a seahawks half shirt
mesh shirt i have a picture of that
somewhere um
and i had one of those old-school
starter jackets with the you know it was
it was that blue
back in the day not the dark blue the
more royal right no it was like the
warren
they were grey helmets that and then
silver they were so
silver yeah yeah and then the giants i
really liked the giants for a minute
when especially when hostetler was there
and dave megan was a maryland guy
who uh and then uh sean landeta went to
school where they both went to towson
where i went and then
the raiders i got into the raiders
that's gotta be so tough i don't
i thankfully don't know what this feels
like i
was faced with this perhaps a couple of
years ago when ralph wilson died we
thought
someone was we thought bon jovi was
gonna buy the [ __ ] team and move him
to toronto so bon jovi
persona non grata in buffalo you play
you play
living on a prayer in a bar you're gonna
get your [ __ ] throat slit all right
that's great advice to let people know
if you go to buffalo do not put
bon jovi in the [ __ ] jukebox so
you're going to die
bon jovi won't come there anymore he's
really he's setting that right he said
in interviews he's like [ __ ] buff
buffalo hates me i hate them
blue rambo out he's never performing
yeah so [ __ ] you and your dog rogers
talking about you know he teamed up with
rogers the people that owned the cell
phones up there and they owned the
rogers center
and they were already sniping us for a
game a year when ralph wilson was alive
so we thought they were all going to
toronto
thankfully the pagulis stepped in
and they prevented both bon jovi and
donald trump from buying the buffalo
bills by the way
donald trump tried to buy it he was out
of that usfl [ __ ]
no it wasn't it was this is something
i'm saying trump this is 2014.
yeah right we could have stopped ran the
usfl underground
i knew that we knew them when you when
you ran to you uh
was it usfl yeah that's right well he
just yeah he [ __ ] that up
he's gonna you can't run a minor league
football
[Applause]
organization he wasn't even the owner of
the organization he was just the owner
of one team and he [ __ ] up the whole
organization
i mean come on i mean come on dude y'all
didn't see it with the usfl i did
i am i'll tell you this i am 100
thankful i will take every moment of
political as i'll get on this
i'm about to get even a little more
political i will take every single
thing that has happened to this country
in the past four years
as long as we've kept that monster away
from the buffalo bills
i'll take it all over again baby four
more years if it means that
because people are like oh don't you
think it's uh it would have been better
if he bought the bills than he would
have been president and i go no
i wouldn't have been the bills would
have been fun those are all i had
yeah i don't care about this country
i'm a fan not a patriot yeah exactly i
[ __ ] hate the patriots
oh [ __ ] okay
uh yeah when when the one thing that
that not having and i did tell the story
of
my biggest honeydew moment of course i'm
supposed to be a ball boy for the 1984
colts i wake up in the middle of the
night my dad and [ __ ] and they're gone
that's that's the story was it the old
trope of moving trucks yeah i just got
out of town there's a great 30 for 30 on
it called the band that wouldn't die
it's amazing barry levinson directed it
um i've never seen that it's the first
one it's the first one that launched the
30s for 30 series
uh but anyway the the thing it did i
told it on comedy central you can go
watch it on youtube
the thing that i did that it did do is
help me learn more
like all of a sudden now i'm discovering
walter payton
you know what i mean and these guys in
seattle like i said and jim kelly you
know you know
how old were you well they left and 84 i
was 11.
okay it was like so you're still young
enough where you're 11. aren't jaded and
you can latch on to a team
i'm jaded because i'm supposed to be a
ball boy well that's that's what i'm
saying it made it worse
i probably wouldn't have been as
affected if i wasn't like
man i'm supposed to be down there doing
that because i don't know if like if the
bills did leave into 2014
i would have been how old uh 18
or no that was how many years ago i'm so
[ __ ] shitty at math six years ago i
would have been 28.
yeah so i would have been jaded to the
point i don't know if i would have been
able to watch football anymore
like it would have been it took a while
for sure it definitely did because you
just don't even know what's going on to
get up on a sunday
i know some people are like shut the
[ __ ] up but for real to get up on a
sunday and not have something to root
for during football season if you're a
football fan
yeah it sucks it sucks to just be like
oh is that who won the super bowl this
year and oh i couldn't imagine
but then all of a sudden you get your
team and we'll talk about that you
wanted to ask me and then the anxiety
comes back and the [ __ ] god
damns come back and you know all the
excitement all that [ __ ] so it's
was there a mixed feeling when you did
get the ravens about
how the colts left you where you did you
feel bad i've talked about that and the
this is not
okay i just say like you know the truth
is that
i didn't no we didn't we wanted the
carolina expansion team or the
jacksonville expansion team we didn't
want someone else's team because we knew
what that was like
you know i say it's like it's like
[ __ ] rooting for your ex-wife to hit
the lotto you know i'm not still gonna
root for the [ __ ] colts
yeah but i also don't want your team
right so from 96
to 99 when cleveland got a team
i was a fan but i just was like you know
it's not
we're building something and we just
took this team
and you know 1999 they say cleveland
don't worry you can have a team and i'm
like wait what
they've never won an nfl super bowl
you've got to go back to the
championships
they haven't done [ __ ] this team is
needed
why why is this team so you hate art
model who
helped pioneer football back in the day
and bring it to the level why the [ __ ]
does cleveland
what royalty of football are you a man
so these [ __ ] get a team and
also
just just to be proper about it and i
know people have their
hate for art model i get it because of
i'm the same way about irsay
but art model left cleveland's records
there so jamal lewis
and jk dobbins ray rice never beat a jim
brown record
that doesn't happen right because these
records are these records i am going to
move the team but i'm going to
rename it i'm going to start a new
history and this team is going to be
this team here it's like you became an
expansion team we became an expansion
team yeah because
again they were so revered they just had
to have three years don't worry don't
worry
we'll get you i can't believe that yeah
these [ __ ] have had
i would wager a top five pick for
two [ __ ] decades and they just get to
the playoffs oh hooray
cleveland you've you should have had 10
[ __ ] super bowls looking
past this already baby we got two we got
two you do
well i'm not looking past you at all i'm
just saying this [ __ ] over there the nfl
they told you know what they said i
lived in cleveland for a year i'm sorry
no i hated it i
did not like living there i i don't
dislike the city of cleveland i just
don't like the cold but you
well i did buffalo i didn't like their
fan base
because of football because bills in
cleveland had very much similar in
common when i lived there where they
both were kind of downtrodden
in terms of their success bills fans
handled it in a way where it was like
who cares
let's [ __ ] rage and every game was
fun and it was a party
cleveland has that but there was also
all that art model ray lewis you know
all that kind of [ __ ] we can't draft a
franchise quarterback yeah we've had a
dozen shots
i'm a big colt mccoy guy i think got a
raw deal but anywho
i uh i just yeah i just never felt i'm
like [ __ ] them i i don't feel bad for
them but i am happy that they've
shaken the monkey off their back as well
and now they're in the
both of us at the same time we're in the
playoffs we have our first home game in
25 [ __ ] years in the playoffs yeah i
know we got to come up to buffalo this
this
this it's going to drop the day after
the game so we'll see what the [ __ ]
lamar's never thrown a touchdown in the
snow you know he's never played in the
snow he said i was well i've watched
everything even even in childhood he's
south florida so he's never
they interviewed like three guys on our
team like yeah i've never played in the
snow i'm like how does that get how do
you get around that you wanna know
what's funny
a bunch of guys on our team probably
haven't either
uh it has but um not like and you don't
have the fancy heated cooler
underneath there no no no they're
shoveling the [ __ ] field
but um i'll never forget this is like a
part of uh my honeydew and my fandom
i've always been obsessed with the bills
but like in 2009
i had media access to the bills i had
locker room access
whoa i had all for radio yeah yeah and
like a couple of years before that but
2009 was where it was like the peak
because we had t.o
i was so down and i saw teo naked i was
like holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] t.o naked it's crazy i'll
bet you his
dick is [ __ ] ripped if you if you
want to feel like
not the same species as another human
being i mean swear to god i felt like an
insect
i'm like his stick is as big as i am and
he's just sitting there talking to like
reporters with it just dangling out
it's not shy no it's out there he looks
like a stalemate
dude yeah dude so i mean that was the
best year but
i had uh media passes leading up to it
and i'll never forget like
drafting guys this is in the worst of
the worst
of the drought we've had like roscoe
parish on our team he played it
at the university of miami southern kid
i swear to god there was a game that
snowed and he was like i'm not going out
there
no he was terrified he had never seen it
before it's like he's never even seen
snow
yeah yeah i'm not going to do that i
guess
i always think about the first people on
earth that saw rain or
thunder like what the [ __ ] yeah right we
have a bunch of the there was a while
there where we were just drafting
players that have never and we were
practicing indoors we're like what are
you doing
go outside like this is the supposed to
be our advantage
and you're getting these guys are like
both teams are like this is [ __ ] up
i'm not
you know what i mean like they both
sucked in the snow so i didn't
understand that at all we're drafting
quarterbacks that play in the south and
like in the west coast
who've like never had a driving wind in
their face
driving you know what i mean like i've
never been to denver and throwing a ball
away
yeah it was just such a dumb
dumb time period uh that we had to grin
and bear through but again
we i handled it in a way where i was
like i'm just happy buffalo has a
[ __ ]
nfl football team here well you guys
take it seriously i
to answer your question and and i want
to tell everybody this is not going to
be a sports podcast only
oh yeah we have other stuff we've got
something else that's awesome that's
what i have to say on my podcast do i go
sorry
people who don't like sports look it's
been a minute for you guys so i get it
but uh when we were
uh raider fans a handful of us rented a
van
and we drove up to see the raiders play
the bills back in your heyday
during your four-year run we might have
been in year three roughly i'm 20
i don't know we used to beat the [ __ ]
out of the raiders too and well it's
funny you say that
so i what i don't know is
at the time i just smoke weed yeah uh
it's still
i just smoke weed everyone else in the
van i don't know
has dropped acid and that's why they've
asked me to drive like you can smoke
when we get there or take a break and
this is one other guy that didn't drink
or smoke so we we would
pass off what time of year is this it's
a winter it's cold as [ __ ]
it's december and they drop acid and
along the route we took the scenic route
of course we're going up through the
mountains and there's these i just
looked it up recently too there were
these
things it was called clyde peelings
reptile world do you know these things
they were like stop along the way [ __ ]
but they'd be attached to a subway i'd
be like there's a [ __ ]
anaconda over there you know i mean a
lizard over there and you can get a six
inch over here it's so weird right
and my brother starts throwing up that's
when i find out i'm like what's him what
did he take what's the matter like we're
all tripping i'm like jesus christ
everybody i don't think they're just
in the van so we drive
and uh we get up to buffalo we drive up
to niagara falls we go at night to see
it and ship
and um what is that where you cross into
canada what time the rainbow bridge
uh is it's just niagara falls into
niagara falls ontario
ontario yeah so um
we come back we go to the game the next
day we partake in the parking lot
tailgates and everything
it's absolutely handsome even back then
because i i mean i
hadn't started my tailgating but there
were people out there with grills looked
like elk and [ __ ] and i was like oh yeah
that's what i'm curious about because i
never got to do that back in the day i
know it always happened but i mean
i've only they were out there the night
before they don't let you do that at the
new stadiums you can't be out there the
night before yeah you can you can be in
the rv lap
8 a.m on a saturday started yeah yeah
they're out there doing that getting
wild
or something like that you know and
they're loaded so we get into the game
and you guys are beating the [ __ ] out of
the raiders but the raiders
no no the raiders are beating the [ __ ]
out of you and you guys come back and
win you're right
and i'll never forget watching three
guys in camouflage
beat the [ __ ] i mean beat the [ __ ] out
of this raiders fan
security just stood there and watched
and i was like oh it gets real up here
in buffalo that's when i learned you all
had jills i didn't know anything about
just we don't anymore
they're gone a little bit of
you know some impropriety is that right
those uh
nfl cheerleading squads are independent
entities did you know that
our radio company owned the jills really
and uh
yeah and they just became a little too
expensive and there was some [ __ ]
going on and so they were just like no
more chills
i'm not gonna have those anymore but uh
that's interesting that you say that
because
again i grew up in a time where we were
not dominant
so we were not beating the [ __ ] out of
anybody in the [ __ ] stadium because
we were always losing
uh you know i never saw a real
violent thing but one of the darkest
times i saw as one of the most times i
was ashamed to be a bills fan
was when colin kaepernick came and
played against us and people were
selling
shirts in the parking lot with like his
face with a target on it
yeah and like a part of me goes well
that that's just them doing that to the
opposing quarterback
but they don't understand the
implications that that
holds when you do something like that
and then you know they're burning them
in effigy i'm like well yeah they do
that to tom brady too but
this has a little more weight because of
the tone of everything going on
and that was a little rough um and i
took mushrooms at that game
[Laughter]
and uh i might i don't forgive me if i
said this before but i
i uh i took the mushrooms and i'm
tripping i'm doing great i'm having a
great time
and there's no i've never gone to a
bills game and made it in before the
national anthem
you know what i mean no because you're
tailgating and then everyone tailgates
and then
you know you're like oh [ __ ] kickoffs in
15 minutes and see if you don't get in
for the oh we get in the yellow
well we we there's people but the
gates are flooded you know there's only
so many ways in
and everyone tries to get in the last
time so the part of the
tradition and the experience is that
moment where you're just in a
throng of people you know waiting to get
inside
and uh i i was on shrooms and i'm
freaking out and we hear the
national anthem start and uh
i i don't know i made a joke like uh i
had to take a piss or whatever and i was
like
kaepernick's kneeling what are they
gonna say when i take a pistor in the
national anthem and i just started
pissing like in the middle of the group
because there's like people blocking me
and i'm like i'm pissing during the
national just
like i don't know why but then
i see in the distance this
uh silver object
coming at warp speed towards me and i
freaked out and hit the i thought we
were being bombed
and it was uh it was the flyover for the
national anthem
after i'm making jokes and [ __ ] i
thought we were getting bombed
i envisioned it in my brain during my
trip just
one of them careening into the side of
the
stadium it [ __ ] me up for a second
dude
and i told my friend i go i was like oh
i thought they were gonna bomb us i
didn't know what that was he goes it's
the flyover man because they don't even
put missiles in those
and i was like it still doesn't matter
oh god damn that is killing me
that was killing me i started getting
crazy i was like rationalizing
my country though you know what i mean
you'd be like yeah i mean there's little
kids in yemen that
[ __ ] their pants if they saw that you
know what i mean they see that every day
they draw them in drawings
it is if you've never seen that man it
is something it's
loud as [ __ ] well when you're tripping
on shrooms and you forget that that's
part of it yeah it's also
a little reminder too like just so you
know if you all decide to [ __ ] around
we'll just drop one bomb kill 100 000
right dude
and then i started getting crazy i'm
like what if an isis like got a hold of
a flyover plane and just was like
they're like josh i think they're a
little secure yeah
they're like i think they're a little
secure about it i don't know you trying
to have a good time
yeah once i got in there though it was
like we beat the texans it was a great
day
great trip what about um well first of
all
happy birthday oh yeah today yeah it's
your actual
birthday today i thought we were gonna
do a birthday but i didn't realize today
was the day so happy birthday thank you
thank you for being here 35 35 years old
on your birthday today so people don't
believe me when i say
how my age by the way why would they
think i'm very much older
i don't i think you're right on there
yeah your beard
gives you maybe yeah i should shave it
or something i don't know if you want
there's a pandemic
people should do whatever the [ __ ] they
want people are dying left and right if
you give a [ __ ] about what somebody's
facial hair looks like or tattoos or
clothes or who gives a [ __ ] i don't even
see anybody anyway to
give a [ __ ] anyway i wish i wish i could
give a [ __ ] it's the mirror that's the
one yeah
yeah yeah that's the tough one to see i
gotta look at this all the time so i
thought
me too i'm just like yeah it's my face i
think then it's
it's bothering me mine's just i'm like
i'm glad the mirror is just showing
my face um but i wanted to share
so we're gonna do some honeydew birthday
stories yeah and
i do have some uh honeydew sports
stories that aren't professional sports
i wanted to share with you oh sure it
does play into the birthdays because
again being a twin you got to share your
birthday which always
sucks [ __ ] but um i remember there were
times like
my brother and i both played sports
together all the time you didn't have a
choice my parents were not gonna go
two different [ __ ] anythings it was
you're both playing this sport
on this team that's it and we tried out
for the
the all-star team and my brother made it
and i didn't
probably i'm like and i have a picture
of this too and i was [ __ ] pissed
because i was definitely better than
some of those kids but they were only
going to take one of us and i was like
these
why is that i don't know i guess they
really didn't think i was
as as good but the shitty thing was i
didn't get to stay
home when my brother had a game i had to
go with him
and my younger brother and watch that
[ __ ] watch these kids make errors and
strike out i'm like
and just to make me feel better they
gave me a t-shirt
like a baseball jersey and i have a
picture of me standing there with that
[ __ ] stupid jersey and a pair of
shorts but my brother's all in the
baseball uniform oh that sucks [ __ ]
hated
[ __ ] i hated that [ __ ] i was like you
[ __ ] that was baseball not
soccer right baseball yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] brutal
that makes you go like did rondae and
tikki ever have anything like that go on
you know what i mean like they both made
it to the end all the watts yeah the
one well the but we were the exact same
age that's the thing we weren't a few
years apart where
well i i want i think rondae and tiki
are twins aren't they yeah they are
they are that's that's crazy but um
and also just growing up like we there
was a soccer team
what actually led to love and soccer was
there was this team that would just
always cut
us for you know because they had they
were very clicky they had the parents
had the team they didn't want any
outsiders we were new and not just us
but there was always a handful
of kids that they were like nope nope
nope so
we had this guy named bill hoffman who
was like well [ __ ] it let's start our
own team
and this dude studied german soccer
he was giving us vhs tapes and [ __ ]
middle school and he's
he's like watch the triangle the whole
phil jackson [ __ ] he's like watch the
triangle we would practice
i'm telling you i'm i'm like 11 12.
we're practicing triangles
you know always you run a box but you
use three people so
here i can pass here dude that's so wide
boom boom
my uh my only coach i ever really had
was my best friend
al's dad who's like the nicest guy in
the world
and he did the triangle thing out of the
gate too we were like little kids
triangle try that's all i remember for
money yeah someone's got to always
hustle to one spot or the other but
there's always somebody open you're
running that triangle so
put on the pete and we would switch the
ball
from we call strong side with the ball
to the weak side he taught us
you know you can pass it across this
whole [ __ ] field to this guy over
here yeah
we're like what so we
formed a team and we took all the
outsiders outsiders
from uh the the people they were cut
and we built this team called south
carol and we
kicked their [ __ ] ass guy you're like
a cobra guy
it wasn't but but for us there was a
team called north carol
who was the perennial winner they were
all every year nor garner
they were the one to beat yeah so when
we got to freedom that's
the team that will cut everybody we
crush them
but nice but while they felt like this
was a huge game for them
we were just like you're just another
one of these pegs on the we don't give a
[ __ ] about you we're going there and we
did and we won we [ __ ] started
yeah it's like mighty duck [ __ ] it was
awesome we'd start winning like every
other year it'll be us and then we'd
lose we win we lose we win when you
earned a [ __ ] trophy
like when if we if we didn't win
anything we didn't get my stepson got a
trophy i'm not kidding you this big for
like fifth place and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you
we had if we were anything after like
third
you got a ribbon for third by the way
right you might have got a medal for a
second you got a trophy with your
[ __ ] name on it first
he got fifth place a big one yeah and
then it's broken in his room and [ __ ]
because he didn't earn it yeah he
doesn't care about it
and if we didn't get anything beyond
that you got a pizza party
the coach would throw a pizza party and
make up [ __ ] like most improved player
and you know
most goals on our team yeah yeah yeah
highest scorer whatever most improved
i took uh karate as a kid
and i used to do tournaments and it was
like when i say karate
i couldn't do [ __ ] to anybody it's it's
glorified dance class essentially you're
doing
katas and [ __ ] i would do a tournaments
though
where you'd do likkatas and stuff you
would yeah all the travel like i'd go to
ohio i go to pennsylvania
all over the country yeah and
i i mean dude the trophies that they had
for these tournaments like regionals and
[ __ ]
were taller than me like yeah tall
[ __ ] trophies and like you'd have to
take the picture where you high kick
next to it so like the kick is the
length of the trophy and [ __ ]
you gotta tie it up on the roof
dude and i don't i'll never forget
winning one
i remember like i it was elusive to me
for years
a couple years but then when i was like
nine i got the big one
and i couldn't even i wouldn't i like
wanted to sleep with it i think if i
knew what [ __ ] was i would have
wanted to [ __ ] that trophy
like i had i had it in my bed with me i
was
did you really dude yeah it was tall it
was eight feet tall dude
in your bed yeah but i i swear i put in
the hotel that night i'm like it's
sleeping next to me
you know my mom's like all right dude
like we could stand it next to the bed
yeah
to yeah you might break it i'm like no
it'll break me that little wing down
there is fine
dude it was the best though and yeah i
never uh they would give you a little
like
medals and [ __ ] but next to that eight
foot tall [ __ ] trophy i look like dog
[ __ ] you're like i want this [ __ ]
stupid metal you know yeah that really
is a thing though huh participation
trophies is real
participation trophies is real hey you
were here and i'm like
i mean i just differ in the sense that
like to me
the reward is getting to play the sport
that's
that's the reward learning what being a
teammate is and camaraderie and and how
to lose
gracefully and how do you learn from
part of the trophy is
not getting it is to lose grace that's
right and that should be more
that should be the angle more than the
[ __ ] winner right
hey you got your ass kicked by here
because there is no
despite the fact that there is no
gloating from winning there there's also
no losing happening that's the
part that's forgotten my look i'm i
believe
in in in helping the kids and everything
my stepson also played a y
a y s o soccer and not the [ __ ] on them
but they do this thing at least in santa
monica called
silent saturday and the parents aren't
allowed to cheer even if they score and
[ __ ] i'm like what the [ __ ] are we
talking
about hell yeah and i'd be like oh and
they turn around look at me i'm like
what and they're like it's silent
saturday i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
it you know how creepy it is to be at a
five sport fields and it's just
silence we're witnessing how creepy it
is right now in the world
watching this [ __ ] pandemic i can't
stand it i can't even [ __ ] i do
you know the nerd in me is like i like
hearing them call their cadence i like
all that [ __ ]
but without like hockey starts today and
it's to be so [ __ ] gross without
people in the in the crowd
it's just ugh momentum and listening
cheering is part of something that
invigorates totally is yes
it's something that encourages you it's
something that can encourage you the
opposite way too like the opposing
cheers and things like that
i was nervous because they allowed bills
fans into the playoff game
they only allowed like 6 000 of them i
was like now we're gonna be too amped up
when we come out because we're used to
not playing without people that's
interesting so i got nervous about it
this week
um it's yeah i don't know i had 15 in
tennessee i couldn't believe i think
we're only still doing like 6 700
but yeah we're gonna be out there in
full force even though it's going to be
like two feet of snow
i hope lamar doesn't get is that really
how much
um i you know i
you think it sucks to have a birthday to
share with somebody it it kind of does
in the sense that you don't
feel you know you don't have a day your
own day
you know what i mean if i was a parent
of twins i think i would do this
whatever the day is i'd make yours the
day before and the other one's the day
after that but the problem is when
you're a kid and you have birthday
parties
people aren't coming for two days that's
also true and your parents are like
what am i a [ __ ] yeah we're gonna
have parties every day and i was never
i never felt like i i got i really
didn't i never felt like i got robbed of
having my own day
rarely did i get my own cake i have a
picture of a old school
uh so we used to do birthdays if we did
them we'd rent out like
a room at the roller rink yeah and then
everybody would just
you know 50 bucks and everybody's got a
whole birthday party
yeah um and i remember i have a picture
of an
someone attempted to do the oriole logo
swinging the bat in the circles like
and then there's a mr t that i mean this
one
it's remember the cartoon mr t and he
had the dog with the mohawk
yeah yeah it's like that mr t and uh
it's just
i'll see if i can dig it up it it's not
good
i'll see like that's a while
um but like we would have birthday
parties at mcdonald's
yeah mcdonald's you could use you used
to have a birthday party that was a
birthday party it was a thing and when
you go out and play on the play place
that's where i first i remember this is
when i first tried
a fi a cheeseburger with ketchup mustard
and onions because that's all they
[ __ ] had
and i remember my aunt going this is
what we got if you want it you eat it
and i ate it i was like oh i [ __ ]
like this and that was the minute it
changed for me right there at that
birthday party
my mom was always like so good at
birthdays like she
you know we did all the stuff like there
was this place called lasertron where
every kid in buffaloes had their
birthday at some point
there was you know um my 13th birthday
my mom got me like a limo and we went to
go see jumanji
at the movie theater that was like my
birthday that's a cool one yeah so she
was really good at that all the time
i uh i remember though when i was really
little
the buffalo bills hindering my birthday
parties though
because there would be a playoff game
yeah
back when i mean between my let's see i
would have been between
four and uh 10 basically
there was always bills playoff games on
my birthday or around my birthday or
like when the party would be happy right
you'd have it on that sunday or yeah
saturday or sunday so i remember being
at a bowling alley
for a birthday one time we did one there
and it was before you know
you had tvs and phones and all this [ __ ]
obviously
my dad brought a tv to the bowling alley
so that the pair so that the parents
could like watch it and
be around the kids as opposed to go to
the bar and like
because he knew people would just be at
the bar i remember having birthdays
where we'd be like
it's time for the cake and everyone's
like yeah one minute like
let's wait till halftime you know like
that kind of thing like everyone's in
one room and i never really got it
i think like i don't know it would have
been a couple of weeks before my
birthday but i remember watching the
greatest comeback
ever the frank wright right we all had
to go to one
you know frank reich's a university of
maryland guy who also had the greatest
college comeback against the hurricanes
did i know that he did it in college and
he did it in the nfl come back kid
it's crazy as a coach
but i uh i remember because that game
was blacked out
in buffalo wow it didn't sell out no
because we were so spoiled
as a fan base so like they're just gonna
go to the super bowl and lose again we
did
but they were right but people weren't
buying all the playoff tickets plus it
was like a blizzard
uh really shitty day i think too in like
the early portion of the day
so it was blacked out so 50 people went
to this woman that worked with my dad
her name was sally we all went to her
house to watch that game
huddled up in this [ __ ] living room
it was better when you could do that
bananas dude this would be super
spreader [ __ ] to the max right now if
you saw this you know
cheering and screaming oh my god dude
yeah but i always i remember sharing my
birthday with the bills
but probably my worst not my worst this
this is like
quasi my best birthday slash like
just a wild moment of turning into an
adult at the same time
i had my 21st birthday was thrown for me
by my the radio station i worked for and
they had a big party
and a band played and i had a unlimited
bar tab i can do whatever i want
there's listeners there my friends are
there whoever
and uh it was the best and i was at the
bar
and i'm getting drinks for people and
[ __ ] i'm talking to chicks and [ __ ]
i'm talking to this one girl and i
i put my hand on the low part of her
back
and i touched another hand and i looked
up and it was my dad
and my mom was there did he turn and see
that it was you
he didn't care he didn't care he didn't
even notice
i just was that's when i was like all
right i backed off
my mom was there it's not like he could
do anything so i was like all right well
but that was like before they divorced
or whatever so i was kind of like
oh okay have you ever said anything to
him about it
ah i don't know i mean we've had so many
like
since then like i've lived with him and
he'd have
chicks over and [ __ ] so i mean it's like
whatever at this point you know
but i don't know if he remember i mean
we were he everyone was wasted i don't
know if he'd even like
remember that birthday party let alone
that moment inside of it
but yeah i've never brought it up to him
never said dad i remember when we held
hands let's call him
hey dad remember uh that brunette
at the bar that day but yeah no that was
uh that's when i started getting a
little
inkling you know i always knew a little
something
but then i kind of was like huh and then
you know sure enough a couple of
years later it was done it was done
yeah let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first sponsor ritual now
do you
really know what's in your multi vitamin
sugars gmo
synthetic fillers artificial colorants
not to mention
animal byproducts like sheep's bowl and
gelatin from hooves and hides are all
ingredients you might find in a
multivitamin but ritual
isn't your typical multivitamin rituals
clean
vegan-friendly formulas made with key
nutrients and forms your body can
actually use there's no shady extras
all right they sent me a bunch of stuff
i'm using them i've been looking for
a multivitamin look i'm 47. i want a
multivitamin that works the stuff i read
like you heard i mean hell there's
sawdust in these things i don't even
know if it's working
all right ritual is the multivitamin
reimagine ritual is formulated with key
nutrients including vitamin d3 to help
fill
gaps in the diet their fresh tasting
delayed release capsules are designed to
dissolve later in less sensitive areas
of the stomach so you can take them with
or without food
rituals made traceable you'll always
know where your nutrients come from
thanks to rituals one of a kind visible
supply chain ritual is designed
with different life stages in mind it's
now available for men women and teens
ritual multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages alright ritual makes healthy
habits easy your multivitamins are
delivered right to your door
every single month with free shipping
always you can start you can snooze or
you can cancel your subscription anytime
and if you don't love ritual within your
first month
they'll refund your first order all
right you deserve to know what's in your
multivitamin that's why rituals offering
my listeners 10
off during your first three months all
right visit ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today our
next sponsor is keeps now as guys so
much of our identity is wrapped up in
our hair from how it feels after getting
a fresh cut
to the way it's perfectly styled before
going out that's why when we get into
our 20s and 30s and start noticing
your first signs of hair loss it
definitely feels like panic time because
let's face it no guy is ever ready to go
bald thankfully now
there's keeps the simple and easy way to
keep
your hair did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way now listen to me to prevent
hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have your hair left
all right you get treated from home you
used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
they make it easy they deliver your
medication every three months
so you can say goodbye to pharmacy
checkout lines and awkward doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there okay you may have tried them
both before
but probably never for this price look i
have a lot of friends that have used
this
guys i know losing hair young and it's
worked alright so
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
honeydew to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash honeydew now let's get back to the
do
i um i'll i pause because i still to
this day i'll never understand
why or who ultimately did this
but the worst birthday uh and i've
talked about a little bell about this
but my younger brother's birthday his
13th birthday is the worst birthday
i've ever his birthday his birthday i
mean we're there
and we're part of this birthday party
but
my father was buried on my youngest
brother's
13th birthday oh my god
like i said i'm not sure who [ __ ] was in
charge yeah
like it was it was a wake and a birthday
party combo
why for real they really were like what
were they like
like all right
uh our father
we're going to do the our father then
the happy birthday man
we're going to read the prayer card then
blow out the candles i'm not kidding you
when i
was it really combined my father's
funeral like we were
we ended up being we played all the
sports and
also we didn't have any parents so every
kid in school came to our place
even kids we didn't know would partied
our place on weekends and [ __ ] so
we ended up being popular kids in school
for
some good reasons some not so good
reasons
uh parents will tell you but
um my dad's funeral was really big and
it was an excused absence at school and
[ __ ]
and then um for the whole school yeah
so many friends and family showed up i
mean there was a police escort it was it
was really
it's a night it was a great send-off it
really was looking back on it but
he died on november 27th and they had a
two-day
you know viewing 28 29 and they buried
him on the 30th which is my brother's
birthday and i just i mean we're up
there eating cold cuts and [ __ ] and
talking people are crying my
grandmother's having a nervous breakdown
and then they bring the [ __ ] cake out
we're like are you
right now and we switched from from
mourning my father
all right to celebrating my birth my
brother's life like
hey guys just lost this one but real
quick
let's squeeze in a little nod to this
one and we'll get back there is this
at least a ride in the police escort and
use the siren or some [ __ ]
people still say [ __ ] to me about it
like
you remember that time your dad died
they had to burn birthday i was like
yeah i remember i remember
i think i do i still think about it
well [ __ ] that trumps my little story
that i was gonna tell about uh my
parents took a vacation on my 15th
birthday i thought that was rude
sharing a cake with a brother is not so
bad you know what i mean
yeah it really puts [ __ ] in for snack
you're like
give me another mr tk yeah it turns out
that pretty one's so bad i guess i'll
share it i'll share
the mr tea cake sounds dope though dude
well i have to
dig up the picture i have it somewhere
i'm trying to remember some cakes man
because my mom definitely
i mean back in the day people get into
the oh yeah get all into the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] my mom was that
that was bad that was she likes that
[ __ ] more than i like that [ __ ] yeah so
it's like i don't remember any of that
but she remembers all that [ __ ]
do you know what i mean like she'd be
like oh you had a cake that was uh
uh ninja turtles and uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't [ __ ] i'm
like
wow yeah man yeah so yeah i know my
parents went to uh
egypt on my birthday one year 15 15
years old
and i was like do i get to go and they
were like no they really went on why
it was your birthday they were there or
they left on your birthday they left the
day before my birthday bam
yeah and i was and they're like you're
15 is it such a big deal
and i was like all right i feel like
kind of a [ __ ] now but
i don't think you should but i do yeah
like when you said it i'm also like yeah
yeah yeah you're like because i was like
i'm 15. i guess
i shouldn't care about my thoughts
i don't remember i'm trying to remember
my 16th birthday
because that's a big deal right you get
your license and i do remember getting
my
my license i told that story on here
about my dad helping with me with the
eye test and all of that but
i also took my my we were talking about
this the other day like
how far after your birthday could you
take the driver test
because i couldn't remember i took it
almost positive
my birthday is march 8th i'm almost
positive i took it on like the 11th
right and that might have been because i
couldn't get there i think you can take
i don't know if she should take it on
the day but i remember like i took
driver's
ed so i could take it on the day i
believe and i'll never forget like the
first time i got to drive in a car
alone like to school like that feeling
was
unbelievable i felt like i could do
anything yeah
and you're like holy [ __ ] this is really
happening right now i'm driving this
[ __ ] car
to school i'm gonna park it i'm gonna
get out of school and get back in it and
try a [ __ ] home
that's nuts and i just remember feeling
like a [ __ ]
i know everything you know what i mean
like the whole world is
in my hands and i was an idiot
and i drove like a [ __ ] [ __ ] that
first year oh my god dude
i just thought i was just driving that
was your first car it was a chrysler
neon
oh i remember the neon okay well it was
like not the dodge not the dodge it was
like chrysler
um i don't know i don't know why it
looked exactly the same
it just had a chrysler logo on it i
don't know why that happened
but uh dude i was
like me and my friends would be going
like to our friends because they
replaced that hood and that trunk on
that car is probably
really probably it is part of that's the
safe i thought chrysler made a neon for
a
spell of time i mean it's dodge chrysler
anyway yeah that's why maybe oh maybe
they made it first and then dodge took
it over yeah maybe
either it was [ __ ] it had a ski rack
on it and [ __ ]
but i uh all my friends you know we had
like these
beater cars my buddy had like a shitty
toyota corolla
i paid 500 for my toyota car and we used
to just drive instead of all driving in
one car
to a place we would all drive our cars
so we're driving around like
[ __ ] [ __ ] did i used to like
cross double yellow lines and pass by my
friend and [ __ ] like
i look back i go jesus christ i can't
believe i didn't die you know what i
mean
oh yeah no doubt and i shouldn't have
been driving in the first place
ah do you remember the first ticket you
ever got um
because mine was like three weeks after
i got my light my my like permit
basically
i do remember the first ticket but the
first interaction i got really lucky
i was coming down a hill and the
retirement community where i work is
right here on the left
his old age home i'm about to make a
left in and just across there's a stop
sign right here
and just across this street is a park
and ride and there's a cop just leaning
on his hood
and he just waves me over and i'm like
i'm late for work
he's like i'm late for him and i'm in a
tux like a fake pseudo tux for this
place and stuff and he's like where are
you going to work i'm like right there i
was coming down the hill a little fast
i'm running a little late
and he totally was like you know slow it
down slow it down but i just remember
like
oh god oh god yeah all that [ __ ] yeah i
mean when i was
i wasn't even drinking or anything at
that time and i was
no drugs or anything was in my car there
was not even anything like that but i
got pulled over i'm like oh my god oh my
god oh my god
and i was with my friends in the car and
i didn't have a working radio at the
time
so we just had like i had a radio but we
didn't want to listen to the radio we
had
cds you know yeah and i didn't have a cd
player
so we had a boom box in the back and my
friend just had it on his lap and he's
like playing the music
and the cop comes up to the window and
he's like you know how fast he's doing
the whole thing
but my friend doesn't turn the radio
down he's just blasting like
lincoln park or whatever and the cops
like not saying anything he's just like
can you can you turn it down a little
bit and my friend's like oh yeah
yeah and then he's like fumbling with it
and [ __ ] and he's like you can't have a
external like radio in your car either
you give me a [ __ ] ticket for that
too no
yeah is that right i don't know that's a
different
sound to sound that's what this is like
before cell phones and [ __ ] too so i
don't know maybe it was like that like
that's what i thought i'm like if it's a
speaker it's a speaker right like i got
that one thrown away
thankfully yeah but he gave me a ticket
for that [ __ ] thing because maybe
because my friend was an [ __ ] or
whatever but
man that was the first of what will
become a lifetime
of police interactions that you got
pulled over a lot all the time dude in
my life
yeah i mean because i [ __ ]
i became it became like this [ __ ] rat
race like
i was poor i was driving a shitty car
and i was an idiot and i treated it
shitty too so i like
all these things perfect storm so like
my inspection would come up i couldn't
afford to fix my car to get my
inspection fixed so then my registration
would come up but i couldn't get my
registration fixed and then my [ __ ]
uh
uh license would get suspended and i'd
get pulled over because my license is
you know what i'm saying so like it's
just yahtzee every time i get pulled
over
plus whatever i was doing that i got
pulled over for you know speeding or
whatever the case
you think i wouldn't speed in that case
but i was
and uh yeah it was just a brutal period
of time in my life that i had to get
cleaned up before i moved out here
because it was going to haunt me forever
like just tickets stacking up not
knowing where they are driving all over
doing comedy too and like having them be
like
in different like municipalities and
then they then they um
start hitting fees and penalties on time
oh yeah yeah i'm still paying uh new
york state like a driver responsibility
fee or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
it's a penalty you pay for getting
points on your license you have to pay
this like quarterly fee
like 400 bucks or something i uh i
that's what i tell my steps on first of
all he's mixed
so i'm like look you're going to be
probably profiled yeah he can't he can't
go uh
i'm going to work yeah no
yeah i i tell them all the time
registration
license insurance just have it all
current don't ever put it on auto
payment don't [ __ ] let it lapse
ever yeah license registration insurance
it's the worst done have it right here
in a little book where you can easily
grab it hand that [ __ ] off whatever just
don't [ __ ] around
i used to play dumb you know i come up
and be like you know your uh
inspection's up i go oh
is it you know like it'd be like a year
and a half
or something like that with something
great like the color of the sticker
wouldn't even be the same like it might
be like really
and they'd be like yeah and so is your
you know your registration like
huh i thought i took care of that i'm
sorry i'll get right on that you know
you try to spin
the tires hoping they let you go and
they don't yeah they never let you go no
then when they go
uh all right hold on i'll be right back
and they take your license and you know
it's suspended
and you're just sitting there waiting
for them to come back like either with
handcuffs or just the fact that they're
gonna tow your car away and make you
like figure out how to get home you just
know that's coming
you've you've been seriously worried
you're about to get arrested for it no i
was
i've been arrested for it you have yeah
i thought about that
i mean i don't know if i've talked about
that but i wait they actually took you
out of the car to rest
tell me multiple times what do you mean
i've had my license suspended
i i don't remember this i had my license
suspended
repeatedly for like three years just
because you didn't keep up on your [ __ ]
well because then i would get us uh [ __ ]
ton of tickets in places i couldn't go
i'd be on the road doing comedy i'm not
going back to [ __ ] you know
driving sport in new york and [ __ ]
going to court and [ __ ] so i
lost track of all of it and there was
too much going on it was like and i
couldn't afford to fix any of it anyway
and you're doing all this out of buffalo
as your base
yeah okay and so i'm working in radio or
whatever making dog [ __ ] money
doing my road gigs and [ __ ] i told the
story about i think
when i went to atlantic city with my
girlfriend who broke her leg i
definitely told that on this podcast
that was
amongst this [ __ ] storm um
but yeah i got pulled over going to my
mom's house to like pick up mail
to help fix this [ __ ] in a
town called williamsville in new york
and so what i learned through this
process is
if i get pulled over on the highway by a
state trooper they're just going to tow
my car
and impound it and then i'd call and get
a ride or whatever
or i can ride with the tow truck i
learned that they don't arrest you
they give you the [ __ ] ticket that
could end up being a misdemeanor or
whatever
uh but they don't arrest you this what
do they do just leave you on the side of
the road
they say you can ride with the tow truck
or call someone or whatever um
but if you are in a certain township
those cops are more bored and
louder and they can arrest yeah because
it is the state troopers just don't
because it would take too much time for
them to like take you to a
wherever they have to take you the and
this is
like so i get pulled over and i'm
thinking i didn't know that
little uh caveat i thought like they
just take your car and that's it
so i get pulled over and uh the cop you
know he says this that
and i know the drill already at this
point because i've been through it a
bunch of times and i'm like
okay sir uh if you don't mind actually
i'm just gonna walk to my mom's house
because it's only a few blocks away
from here he goes walk what do you mean
you're under arrest and i was like oh no
i get it i mean uh
you're gonna be the ticket the car goes
away i'm under arrest whatever
and he's like
i just meant like i'm not gonna ride
with the tow truck he goes no you're not
riding you're riding with me
you're right because you're going
because yeah that's what i was like i
still didn't get it i'm like i guess
it's right there what's the deal he goes
yeah uh he's a
turn around for me or whatever and then
he does the whole like handcuffs me
thing
reads me the [ __ ] for real yeah but
you've been arrested before this is your
first time getting arrested for this
it was my first time getting arrested
for this it was my first time second
time getting arrested ever
i was i had a dui or whatever years
before that
and uh they didn't even do that [ __ ]
by the way when i got my dui i don't
remember getting
you have the right to remain you know
that whole thing but this guy did it for
this and i'm like it's like 3 p.m on
like a wednesday i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm going to jail now for this
and i went they took me into a holding
uh center
and i sat in a cell by myself until like
i called
i thought you know i get this one phone
call but they let me call a couple
people
they were nice so i call my roommate's
boyfriend
and i go where's gabby like i couldn't
find i couldn't get a hold of her
i was like i need her to get money out
of my dresser and come down and bail me
out cause i'm like who am i gonna call
you know
so she the roommate boyfriend is like
she's in class right now
so when she gets out i'll tell her and i
was like [ __ ]
you know who knows how long this is
gonna be so they take
my [ __ ] glasses my hoodie string
my shoelaces all that [ __ ] because
they're like oh you know you can hang
yourself or whatever
or stab someone with the glasses i gotta
watch somebody
i'm like how long am i gonna be in here
for years like what the [ __ ] are we
talking about like
i'm just waiting for my bail money your
[ __ ] glasses yeah they don't care
because they're like well they're like
for what well so house
what the [ __ ] does anybody wear glasses
of course but what do you need them for
when you're in a [ __ ] cell
you know you got to see the [ __ ] on the
wall
what do you see without your glasses not
really but i mean what percentage could
you would you
i don't know man i mean like to hear i
don't know like everything's blurry
and whatever but so i mean i'm in a jail
cell without being but you are
like solo they're all solo shells thank
god
or solo uh cells and there's like
[ __ ] maniacs in a couple of them but
they're like
this is like williamsville new york so
like they're like white drug dealer
type guys they're like this [ __ ] whack
you know like that kind of [ __ ] you're
like all right there [ __ ]
your name's probably tristan or whatever
the [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah so you had
that but so it wasn't like scary it just
sucked it was just me and like a toilet
and i tried to like lay down on the
bench and like sleep
and i'm like i'm counting on my [ __ ]
flaky roommate to come and bail me out
sure enough she comes and she bails me
out and like
she's getting in trouble at the police
station too because her and her
boyfriend are like making out on the
waiting room
bench or whatever while like they're
waiting to de-process me and they're
like
ma'am uh can you stop like they're like
yelling at i'm like are we gonna get out
of here you're gonna make us go i'll go
back in here [ __ ] relax
and uh it was just awkward because then
i owed you know i had to
they could get the bail money back but
she had to bail me out i only had
300 in my dresser and it was like 600
bucks or something like that so she had
to help me out
so i owed her money now it was a [ __ ]
nightmare i went home that day i'm like
i can't believe i was in jail
like for two hours i can't either excuse
me and you said it happened again
yeah i got and then i got i got put into
another one one time for the same thing
yeah different part of the world
different state
that kind of thing they literally but
that one was more that that one was like
they didn't make me have bail or
anything like that it was just they held
me
and then they i don't know if they
thought it was like a child support
because i guess that's a thing like
they'll suspend your license if you owe
child support
and so they i think that that's what
they held me for that time they were
like
they never really told me but they just
let me go with a ticket
after us like just a little while but i
did have to go in the car
to the [ __ ] cell blah blah blah so
that was brutal that was a communal one
but again i wasn't in there for very
long
it was like only like that just sucks i
didn't you know i didn't think anybody
actually take you in
i guess it's technically a warrant then
huh yeah no it is yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's definitely a warrant
which is so weird when you get told that
you have a [ __ ]
warrant out for yourself because you
don't even know what it's for but then
also it's a strange feeling to then
go like okay and then also i had to
operate
by draw i had to work still so i i knew
this was going to happen but i still
went out and did it anyway i remember
donnell rollings
i told him about it one time i worked
with him i'm like might
i feel like you know driving home is
kind of dicey for me and blah blah and
he's like
man you didn't tell me he was black
because i was like lamenting in all of
my like like my ah my [ __ ] suspended my
blah blah
that's what he said to me when i was
that's great that was like in 2014 or
something like that
have you had accidents car crashes i've
only had
uh it's ironically enough i've only had
two
and they were one was one was my fault
and one wasn't and the one that was my
fault was like right around my
17th birthday actually be i was just
driving
uh kind of fast you know like down a
busy four-lane street
and the cars ahead didn't have brake
lights on so i thought they were moving
and the light was was green but they
had just turned green and they had just
started moving
and i didn't notice that they were kind
of still standing still
until it was too late and there was ice
and i slid right oh [ __ ]
yeah back of a car so that was my first
accident when i was like 17
and i got that car fixed and everything
like it didn't total my car
it wasn't that big of a it crumpled the
hood and ship but i got it fixed
and then a guy ran a red light and
t-boned me and that
was destroyed and i it was like like
right in my
it wasn't a full t-bone it was in front
of my legs like
where the i guess that's a quarter panel
i mean the airbags went off and [ __ ]
and i am in the door like i went i went
like um
it was in the middle of an intersection
obviously and then i went like up on a
grassy patch and i just remember my door
was like already open by the time
i realized what the [ __ ] happened i'm
like on this thing and i was heading to
a gas pump by the way which was
the most scary part like if that grass
wasn't there i would have [ __ ]
flew into that gas pump and probably
exploded damn but like i [ __ ] stopped
on the grass but my door
was just like open so i just like got
out
and i was shocked and i'm just standing
there like what the [ __ ]
everyone's like i got i got his plate
like i was gonna go off no no he wasn't
going anywhere i don't know people were
just like
i saw everything here's my name you know
like they come up to you not like are
you okay
so you're in the right you're crossing
through and he just runs nobody guy ran
a red light
and just crushed in a van yeah damn yeah
that was intense
so what end were you sore as [ __ ] what
happened dude
i can't believe it either he must have
like hit the brakes or something like i
i never really like got the like uh
it was just such a shocking experience
and i did feel that night i was like
laying in bed like i felt like i was
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of me [ __ ]
yeah and um because i walked away from
it
i like walked home it was at the corner
of my street i walked up i walked home i
was like you're not walking anywhere
dude i walked because it was at the
corner you can go to the hospital or
anything nothing
i walked home and i told my mom what
happened and then uh she was like what
the [ __ ] and like
you know i had the police report or
whatever so she thought it was my fault
at first i was like no i didn't do it
you know so she's like i can't believe
it and then um
did you see the guy did you get into
with him no i didn't even i i saw him
but he was kind of [ __ ] up so he
didn't
uh and then i felt i thought i did
something wrong like i didn't really
know
it happened so fast yeah then you're
replaying it like all right did i have
the light
yeah yeah and i'm seeing the light in my
brain like you know i was like was the
sun in my eyes that i missed it and i'm
telling the cops like talking to me he
knows i'm shocked he's just like
so when you went through the light what
color was it stale green was it uh you
know what i
what i mean like asking me all this [ __ ]
and i'm like i
i i can't i just couldn't even talk
and i was i'm walking around and they're
like maybe you should sit down and i'm
like
i can't i'm like juiced you know what i
mean it was like i just got off stage or
something i was like amped up
you know so i like walked home i just
[ __ ]
told my mom that's crazy dude it is i
mean
they asked me like do you have to go to
the hospital anything like that and i
was like
no i don't think so i don't want to
that's the thing yeah we don't want to
yeah i don't want to [ __ ] go to the
hospital
i don't even go to the hospital when i
should go to the hospital
do you go get checkups and stuff not at
all really
not at all you don't go to the doctor
and get a yearly physical
or have not in a very long time do you
go to the dentist
i have gone more frequently than the
doctor for real
yeah you take more care of your teeth
better
do you have something against it do you
think it's [ __ ] i'm no no no no no
i don't want to know i'm i also like i'm
terrified of it i don't want to go to
the dentist either but at least they're
not going to be like you're mortally
friend of mine he don't want to know
either and it's like
and then lana told me a friend of hers
went to the doctor for the same reason
and they're like you have diabetes you
have this and if you'd just been here a
year ago we could have stopped this well
that's the thing like what
a part of you wants to go but i can't
get myself to do it
like i have to have someone they're
gonna find something of course even if i
have to minor you have authority the
anxiety of uh
going is what stops me yeah i have to
have someone like legitimately like be
like tomorrow's the doctor
i'm taking you you know what i'm saying
like it's like a child but i mean i
[ __ ]
will not do it on my own because i don't
i don't know what it is i just get
such anxiety even like they'll lead up
to it that's good
physical together i even said to tom he
brought it up like doing it for content
and i was like that's
probably the only way that i would do it
if tom doesn't then i will gladly take
you
to go get your physical yeah man i don't
uh i would like to know
like the blood stuff i've never had any
of that done so
i go twice a year and every time i go i
was there today again
i do urine i do um
a whole lipid blood panel i do
once a year i do an ekg and a chest
x-ray
i just went um on friday for a calcium
scan on my heart
because of all the heart history and i
had zero
anything blockage at all um there's some
[ __ ] on my lungs i gotta i got a watch
or something like that and like i gotta
go back in a year
to get checked or something but the last
time i went to a doctor and got a
physical it was because my job made me
go do it
otherwise they're gonna raise my [ __ ]
health insurance
where's your content right there tom
makes you [ __ ] go do the physical
well i uh well in this case why i did it
and um all i needed to do was get the
physical and then that's that
and i went into the doctor and she was a
woman and uh
she goes how much do you smoke a day i
told her and she's like you know she did
her
stuff on me and she goes like oh you're
up you're looking pretty good and i was
like really
i thought you're gonna tell me some bad
stuff here you know i don't remember she
told me like
my numbers or whatever she's like yeah
you look you're pretty healthy blah blah
and this is when i was 24 so i better
have been healthy but she goes
uh here's the thing the forms to go do
the blood testing and all of that
i walked out of the doctor i was like
never did never [ __ ] went
i got my note for the premium to go down
and that was all i
came for so i've never gotten the blood
stuff
yeah that's that'll save your life i
guess yeah i guess
i guess i mean sure i'm sure
i feel fine i i mean like i just uh
i'd like to know for the curiosity
because if i if i come out
for the health well here i'm out for the
benefit i don't even know how about
honestly the best case scenario is i
come out and all my [ __ ] looks great and
i go
hey i was right all along i've been
treating this thing like a [ __ ]
amusement park ride
for 35 years now holy hell
that's the first time i said that what's
most detrimental though is
is uh genetics i mean there's nothing
you can do about that
if it's passed on it's passed on you
know so that's why you got to look out
for it my grandma
my grandfather my dad's dad
died early was early like when my dad
was 12 i don't know how old he was he
was an old man
when my dad was 12 and he had like a
heart attack so they say
but i don't know it could have been some
weird egyptian [ __ ] going on egyptian
[ __ ] because he was like
he was like a cab driver and [ __ ] and he
boxed on the side i don't know
so and he was always getting into
getting into it greeks and the egyptians
because my dad and his family were greek
people and they were treated uh
differently than you know by egyptian
people native to the country or whatever
so he would always be getting in fights
and [ __ ]
so my uh my grandma though lived till
she was like a million years old like
she was like a [ __ ]
rock like nothing did she smoke or drink
or any of that or all of it
i don't think she smoked her or drink to
be honest with you i don't know if she
drank to be quite honest but she ate
like [ __ ] you know what i mean like
she ate greek [ __ ] you know what i mean
she's making lamb and rice and [ __ ]
every day
so i don't know she she didn't have the
best lifestyle you know
so uh but she was like immigrant uh
stock yeah you know so she was hearty
and on the other side
my grandparents lived very old uh my
grandma had like every cancer under the
sun and kicked its ass
really she lit her body was like made of
iron
like nothing could kill her but her
brain
deteriorated like 15 years before her
she actually died so she was like
in my eyes dead well before and i'd
imagine that's the route my mother's
going to go that's what my mom got
covered
and she was like oh no i'm positive i'm
like you're going to be fine
you're going to be just like grandma she
is huh yeah yeah
i can already see the signs you know
what i mean she's like one of these i
mean my mom is very fit
and she like pays attention to her diet
and everything like that so she's like
adding that on top of the fact that she
has the genes
of like being a physically stout and
like
able to fight these types of things but
her brain is going to deteriorate
swiftly before her body oh yeah like
well before
and i imagine i'm going down that same
path
well then let's talk about what do you
what are your
birthday plans because i got lucky this
last year
i got lucky my birthday march 8th like i
said it was
a week before five days before this [ __ ]
all went down
so what is a what's a coveted birthday
party dude i think it's going to be
nothing um i'm going to play nhl 21 i'm
going to debut my nhl's
drive oh no no i'm not you don't want to
get arrested
i've stopped driving for the good of the
world
it it does suck like not being able like
sometimes i think i'm like
what if i just want to go like big bear
or something yeah or roll up the
coast not driving has been
during coronavirus been
fantastic you know this is the time to
drive yeah and like just to get out of
the house and stuff like that i don't
have i don't have that option
get in your car roll the windows up and
just go listen to music i'd love to do
that right now
listen that feeling that you had when
you first got in the car like holy [ __ ]
right behind it is being on quarantine
and lockdown and being able to get in
your car and just go anywhere
i bet man i shoot their home school my
daughter and i just get in the car and
we'll go to
[ __ ] we just ride dude i haven't
driven a car in
three years i'll come get you we'll come
get you but what i
think i could rent a car like what if i
just went to who's going to say no now
you should why don't you run well you do
just go for it dude i've actually kind
of like i was thinking about that
like i think i would be scared to drive
right now
you have a license do you have a valid
driver yeah yeah yeah i think unless
they suspended it again
that insurance well you probably don't
have insurance do you i pay for the
rental insurance eh oh yeah i guess you
don't have to be an insured driver
no that's why you buy that insurance
well there you go then
you dude you got to do that please rent
the car and just go for it dude
josh potter goes that's like it's like
being like tom and bert go play
basketball nothing bad could happen
he got a seven car pile yeah i just
think it's like
on the 101 today it's like [ __ ]
chopper overhead
we've got a major axe there's not even
traffic folks and
somehow this guy it would be great you
should just definitely i'm telling you
rent yourself a convertible get a little
vitamin d while you're out there
roll down to san diego i'm back take a
trip up in the hills
james yeah it's nice ride and ride
so far during this uh i've driven
mulholland
a couple times snaked all the way from
the 405 over and back
um i went out to the i've gone to like
the valley in different places christmas
lights [ __ ] like that like
i've done that in quarantine but with a
with like a girl like the girls driving
and then you know you just drive around
and then
you go all right this looks dark i had a
guy during quarantine
uh i was like in a car hooking up with a
girl
up in the hills and uh it was near that
restaurant uh
yamashita yamashiro yeah that's a great
spot
that's where they're doing the outdoor
shows really yeah that's the way they're
doing the alcohol oh they're doing the
magic castle down there i'm sorry yeah
right
yamashiro's right above it yes so i just
went for a drive with a lady friend and
we went for a little walk around the
yamashiro area and this is a beautiful
picturesque things for people who don't
know
you see like out off the hills you could
see like the skyline of the city and
[ __ ] like that yeah really pretty
yeah overlook and like you can go walk
down into these they got these benches
and stuff and it's like a little park
and i went at night with this girl we
went for like a little walk
i got a [ __ ] while i'm just looking
out over la like a goddamn
i felt like i was a king [ __ ] yeah dude
it was the best [ __ ] maybe i've ever
received with the circumstances still
didn't come
no but then we went to the car
and we were hooking up in the car and a
guy yelled out the window
of his apartment going like her house or
whatever he's just like
can you get the [ __ ] out of here
and i'm like oh [ __ ] it didn't at first
i didn't think he was talking to us
but he was he's like can you [ __ ] do
that somewhere else
i'm calling the cops
i just need to get my dad that's what i
said i was like come on cops and then
the girl freaked out cause like he said
cops i'm like he's not gonna call the
guy the cops aren't even like responding
to robberies right now
for real you know what i mean like the
windows got smashed at this [ __ ]
they got looted and the cops didn't care
if they arrest you for getting your dick
stuck
call off the cops are barely responding
to gunshots
in los angeles right now they're not
coming
[Music]
fellatio i think a guy getting his
dick sucked during a quarantine in a car
is gonna
the lapd is going to laugh at this guy
oh is that what's going on here
okay we'll be right back he'll be right
there we'll get him right over there oh
my god that's a guy that had his dick
sucked in along that's what i said i was
like [ __ ] this guy
yeah this is exactly what you need bro
oh yeah hater
[ __ ] hater just trying to get my dick
sucked through a deadly pandemic a
[ __ ] pandemic i'm just
trying to get my dick sucked at
yashamiro whatever
oh great
you're so over it yeah i've never heard
a guy just be so like
just fed up from come on just like like
you're in his bedroom like i was doing
it in front of him yeah
like we're not like in the you have to
look out the window down at the car to
see
me getting a blur probably also a dime a
dozen over there through his products i
don't know there was cars parked but
like
we're not making any noise like what's
he he this guy's and you don't come
loud because you don't come at all so
this guy's [ __ ] what edna kravitz or
some [ __ ] looking out the window being
like could you not
yeah could you not that's what it sounds
like yeah
just a [ __ ] hater and a pandemic
oh brother well thank you for coming on
here this has been thank you happy
birthday for real thank you no i
appreciate it listen
good luck uh next year because i hope we
beat the [ __ ] out of you this weekend
likewise
[Laughter]
well one more time uh please hit it up
uh oh yeah so uh the josh potter show
every tuesday just like uh when you wrap
up the honeydew you can come watch the
josh potter show over on the ymh
youtube channel uh twitch.tv slash josh
underscore potter i'm embarking on
nhl now that hockey season is here
and uh it's a way for me to just talk
out loud you know what i mean i go on at
night
get a couple hundred people in there
it's been pretty pretty dope so
join me on there and uh if you are in
the west palm beach area march 21st i'm
gonna be
at the improv tickets are on sale all
right brother congrats on that
good luck to you this weekend for real
youtube thank you
if it can't be my team i guess it's you
know i don't want the chiefs or the
browns so
yeah i'm with you on that i'd like to
see you guys if we if you knock us out
i'm rooting you all the way same here
you deserve a super bowl you've been to
four
yeah you know you i don't want to know
what happens dude you want to know what
i love if you get to five and you lose
five
it's the pandemic any professional team
ever lost that many
championships i don't know dude and i
don't want to find out but
i'll tell you what i um at this point
i'm playing with house money you know
what i mean
we had our first playoff game and first
home playoff game in 25 years and we won
it
and now everything else is cherry that's
right yeah that's right
all right well good luck to you as
always uh ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all
next week
[Music]
you